my name is Jean Ben reason I'm a
professor in civil and environmental
engineering at Carnegie Mellon and I'm
the director of our sin
for water quality in urban environmental
systems or water quest the water energy
Nexus which is a new hot term at lots of
different levels in the nation in
discussing this is really not a new
concept water has always been necessary
for energy generation and for energy
extraction and then the newest area
where water interacts with energy is in
things like shale gas development which
has been actively discussed quite a bit
over the past two years the need for
water and what's called hydraulic
fracturing the hydraulic that tells you
its water and fracturing we're trying to
break apart the shale so that the gas is
easier to release so when you do that
you use a lot of water and then you
produce a lot of waste water and much of
my research has been on the end of
what's that water like that comes back
up and it comes up really really salty
saltier than the ocean by like ten times
so what do you do with really really
salty water so when you are extracting
energy and producing these waste waters
you have to think sort of three steps
ahead that's really hard for us even as
engineers it's hard for us to think
three steps ahead what will happen to
this water not when it gets in the river
but when it gets in the drinking water
plant and when it gets in the people and
so that's a lot of the work we do at
that system's level saying what if and
what's the next downstream effect of the
energy choices we're making we've seen a
big trend over the last century of
people transitioning from living on
farms to living in cities that process
is not unique to the United States
that's affecting the entire globe and
countries that have large and increasing
populations are also becoming
increasingly urban so we've seen the
development of what are called mega
cities cities with more than a million
people and when you look at mega cities
the infrastructure challenges are just
totally different there's a lot of water
individual people need and there's a lot
of waste water individual people produce
and the same with energy getting the
energy resources into a city like New
York City is really challenging no city
is ever with its boundaries sustainable
a city can't feed itself it can't
produce its own energy it can't produce
its own water it's always importing
resources and exporting wastes and
managing that at the level of the number
of mega cities we're going to have on
the globe as we approach 2100 is really
challenging and so the urban work we're
doing here and a number of other urban
institute
toots at carnegie-mellon are focused on
this really big question of what's the
world going to look like when most of
the population of nine billion people
are living in these large dense urban
environments so the urban rot water work
is informed by what we do in Pittsburgh
but has applications in lots of other
cities